passera passera pas les syndicats sont
vent debout contre la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui devrait entrer
en application le 1er juillet prochain
le 21 mai au matin sept syndicats ont
déposé un recours en référé au conseil
d'état ainsi qu'une saisine sur le fond
il espère que la plus haute juridiction
suspendra provisoirement la réforme
il faut dire que cette réforme ulcère la
direction régionale de pôle emploi est
occupée jeudi à lyon et des
manifestations sont prévues ce week end
alors pourquoi ce projet gouvernemental
irrite il autant syndicat des
allocataires parce qu'ils les un grand
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi son
principe est de modifier les règles
d'indemnisation des chômeurs en
redéfinissant le calcul du salaire
journalier de référence
jusqu'ici calculées sur la base des
jours travaillés il le sera désormais
sur celle des jours travaillés et chauve
et ceux qui baissent automatiquement son
montant qui sera pénalisé bien les
travailleurs les plus précaires qui
alterne périodes d'activité et de
chômage
les temps partiels les saisonniers les
métiers de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration du tourisme
bref ce que l'on appelle les permis tant
l'unedic chargé de la gestion de
l'assurance chômage a estimé que
l'allocation moyenne seraient ainsi
réduits de 17% pour 1,15 million de
demandeurs d'emploi
l'état lui ferait une économie d'un
milliard d'euros par an mais sur le dos
des plus fragiles en novembre déjà le
conseil d'état avait retoqué une partie
de la réforme annulant deux dispositions
phares notamment le fameux calcul du
salaire journalier de référence dans sa
communication le conseil avait pointé
une différence de traitement
manifestement disproportionné le montant
du salaire journalier de référence
pouvant pour un même nombre d'heures de
travail varier du simple au quadruple
c'est pour éviter ces inégalités
d'indemnités que le gouvernement a dû
revoir sa copie la ministre du travail
elisabeth borgne a concocté un décret
rectificatif pour que le congé maternité
les maladies le chômage partiel ne grève
pas le montant des indemnisations
chômage mais on ne fait pas entrer des
ronds dans des carrés l'unedic estime
que ce décret ne corrige qu'un tout
petit effet de la réforme et qu'il est
juridiquement fragile
avec cette promesse de campagne qu'il
s'est engagé à réaliser vaille que
vaille le gouvernement joue gros
la réforme qui devait être appliqué en
juillet
1020 a été suspendue qui est reportée
mais il s'entête au plus mauvais moment
en pleine crise le comble même là des
murs de cette réforme muriel pénicaud
ancien ministre du travail s'est permise
de critiquer son mauvais timing
rappelons les chiffres le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi a augmenté de 4 7%
depuis la crise du coc vide
or comme le rappelait muriel pénicaud en
milieu de semaine lors de la réforme du
temps d'edouard philippe l'emploi était
plus florissant je ne commande pas
l'action du gouvernement mais il faut
continuer à discuter car il faut
vraiment une réforme adaptée au contexte
un soutien plus qu'inattendu aux
partenaires sociaux
mais les syndicats estiment avoir
suffisamment discuté ils demandent que
cette réforme soit tout simplement
retiré le retrait de la réforme c'est
une réforme injuste
c'est une réforme qui va pénaliser
encore plus ceux qui sont déjà dans la
même grande précarité et on sait bien
par expérience de ces années passées que
c'est pas en s'attaquant aux chômeurs
qu'on crée de l'emploi
les intermittents eux ont prévenu tant
que ce ne sera pas le cas les lieux
culturels seront occupés la réponse sur
le recours en référé est attendue d'ici
la fin du mois